joining me here uh once again on the
rich eisen show my colleague from the
nfl media group none other than ian
rappaport back here on the rich eisen
show how you doing ian
i'm i'm
i'm doing better than urban meyer
dude man so let's jump into it um let's
just jump into it would you like to talk
about that today yeah you know what uh
so was it the josh lambo was he the last
straw
is that what this was i you know i'm not
so sure about that i mean
i'm like technically it was because it's
the last thing that happened
um
i
i felt like the wheels were in motion
anyway
now maybe the jaguars caught wind of the
joshua i mean they commented on the josh
lambeau story before it was published so
maybe they knew was happening but i was
at the owners meeting in dallas
and i sort of sensed something was
happening before then
just talking to people in the
organization
um when
you know judy bautista got shot khan he
said stay tuned
um we weren't sure if he meant covert
changes or urban changes but stay tuned
was kind of like okay that's interesting
um
but anyway so
i think once the tom pelosiero story hit
and it was basically you know sometimes
these like sort of explosive bombshells
hit and then everyone denies everything
the denials were not even really denials
it was kind of like well like yeah this
happened but maybe like we saw it in a
different way like that's what they were
and then the lambo thing came out and
there was a denial on that story but
like also far-fetched and hard to
believe i think what was gonna happen
for the jaguars was
these were just gonna come forever
like i was already working on something
for sunday on urban meyer
just on
the dysfunction more and it was and i'm
sure everybody else was too it was all
gonna keep coming
firing him now made sense if only just
to end the story and move on with the
rest of our lives well if you're not
going to use it for game day morning you
might use it on a thursday edition of
the rich eisen show uh ian i mean
because it's all going to come honestly
it's still newsworthy it's still just
because he's been
fired doesn't mean that
that the the level of of the way things
were being
dysfunctionally run is not newsworthy
you got something for me no that's true
uh i'll i'll properly vet it maybe we'll
talk about it on sunday but i think the
main thing
is
um you know there was so many missteps
like it's almost unfathomable like he
hired an outwardly
racist
strength coach and i talked to someone
else today who interviewed with him
and in that interview irvin defended the
hiring of chris doyle to that person in
the interview so it's like it's not like
oh made a mistake didn't realize crystal
it's like he thought that was a really
good move
like delusional
absolutely he thought tim tebow was a
good signing
five years after he'd been in the nfl at
a new position
just because tebow could like help him
with the locker room and kind of be his
like guy on the inside like who thinks
that's a good idea
like there's so many unbelievable
missteps and like i'm not even sure how
great of a coach he is like the football
looks really bad too you know
well the the thing that it just again
for somebody who was totally you know um
uh known widely industry-wide as the ceo
coach right he knows exactly what
everything's going on like this past
week safety andre cisco looks like he's
gonna
play more snaps uh
coach yes no and he's just like yeah
he's he's been out there a lot more i
don't have the numbers in front of me
and he had zero steps zero and it's just
like what's up with that definitely rich
honestly yeah that's when i knew he was
getting fired
that right there
i knew he was getting fired and i
started
working on it and looking at it i mean
they just
you knew because he was so disengaged he
was so clueless
he didn't know his players he obviously
didn't care i mean i i shouldn't say
that the handshake with grebel was when
i was like all right this thing is
ending pretty quickly why i i'm not
seriously why i knew why why
why he's interested
looks like he didn't care
i mean body language is is real like
urban meyer wanted to be literally
anywhere else in the world besides
shaking mike rabel's hand on the 50-yard
line
he was done
in rap report here uh on the rich eisen
show uh what next then
what happens now
do you think for both urban jacksonville
start with jacksonville what do you
think is next uh
we'll start with jacksonville hopefully
hire a better coach no
yes
that said um what do you think there
what do you think
you know
first of all here's this is not my this
is just my opinion
i am annoyed people are saying they need
to hire the best offensive coach
it makes no sense to me
belichick carol
tomlin
best coaches in the nfl
a lot of them are defensive guys just
hire the best leader you can get a
coordinator to like scheme it up and
make trevor lawrence better you can get
a personal quarterback coach who only
does quarterback stuff to follow him
around and make sure that he has good
funding like hire someone to lead your
organization whatever urban wire was
supposed to be hire someone who actually
is
um
and to me i mean that's that's an
obvious one and you know i don't know
which direction it's going to go but
there are some good leaders out there
and some of them you know i they
interviewed some good ones last time and
robert saul was interviewed last time
um eric the enemy was interviewed last
time you know depending on how that
interview went i'd be curious if he got
it
if he got another interview
byron leftwich was a former jaguars
quarterback yep he is a
coordinator of a pretty good football
team and has earned the respect of a
pretty good quarterback
um and is a leader because he's a leader
because he played quarterback i mean
those are some names too i would say
college names
uh probably not of course no i mean
there's no way they go into college
names i mean that that they've already
tried that with the most successful guy
and and and uh you know and i with all
due respect to other college names that
could be coming out i'm i'm shot con i'm
like i don't even want to hear that
right now i'm going with somebody who
doesn't need training wheels in the nfl
somebody who knows how perfect example
as you said to be a leader of the
organization everything that urban
wasn't i want someone who is but i
definitely want someone who is was that
on offense i got to have that for trevor
lawrence and i know you just mentioned
some great names who aren't supposedly
offensive guys john harbor's another one
right comes from the special teams world
uh sean mcvay is all of that with the
rams and he turned jared goff into what
i needed him to turn him into and that's
what i want i want somebody who can do
that whether it's the enemy because he
saw he did that with uh with mahomes or
whether it's mcdaniels because look what
he's doing with mac jones for crying out
loud right now and i know that they have
a another system that doesn't look like
jacksonville's but you know day ball
maybe with what he's done with
josh allen you know those are the guys
that i'm i'm targeting right now
and and left which obviously
you know would know what to do with
somebody as talented as trevor lawrence
uh because and i'm not and i'm not gonna
discount him because he's not he doesn't
have a rookie
he he's got a guy who's very particular
i would imagine and what he likes to do
and he's totally made it work with not
only the quarterback but the coach who
knows he's very particular in what he
likes to do what leftwitch has done is
remarkable so those were games i look at
you know
left which makes a lot of sense and i
think he would probably want it um josh
i guess let's say let's go down the josh
mcdaniels road
i personally think he will be a very
good head coach a second time around i
thought he showed sides of being a good
head coach the first time around and
then he got involved in personnel and he
made a couple dumb moves and like i it
was i think it was all too big for him
at that time
um
i just
let me ask you
do you think josh would want it
like it is an organization that has
had struggles all the way yeah you know
i heard that too but they the
jacksonville jaguars were once stephan
gilmore batted pass away from making the
super bowl man with doug marone and a
guy who who who who belichick told the
khan family to hire you know as as their
full-time
so you know it hasn't been all terrible
with the khan family in charge at all
and the khan family just look at aew
they know how to turn something new into
into gold star like platinum i mean
whatever the most valuable metal is so
they're not clueless and and there's no
state tax it's trevor lawrence yeah i i
i i'd kind of jump on that right now and
you got looks like you might have the
second overall pick you could get
you know uh hutchinson if the lions go
with thibodeau or vice versa
i mean you can get a really good
defensive player atop this draft and go
with trevor lawrence and atn coming back
i don't know
there's nothing when bill belichick is
advising his people
and i don't just mean patriots people
belichick actually talks to a lot of
right candidates and all of the you know
he's actually very influential in the
nfl all over the place
nothing is more important than the owner
nothing and
you know if you're josh mcdaniels like i
mean
there's definitely some things to like
is it perfect i would not think so
facilities aren't good
um the weather is probably pretty good
they got some good fried fish down there
which i like
um here's the other thing i'm going to
be so so interested and i don't know the
answer to this but i'm going to be so
interested what everybody thinks of
trevor lawrence after having watched him
for a year
and
whether they blame urban for his
struggles
or if they still think of them as the
number one pick talent like that
evaluation is going to be really
interesting wow i mean
how about this uh i'll i'll take them
off their hands you know i mean come on
look you know how it works that there's
generationally talented players and
there still is
the nature part of it and the nurture
part of it regardless of how talented
these people are okay i mean that's a
fact
and
there seems to be you even pointed out
again uh ian rappaport from nfl network
here on the rich eyes show you pointed
out that you had something in uh in the
shoot that you're still vetting about
what's going on in jacksonville or what
has gone on in jacksonville on sunday
we're probably only knowing about what
30 of it
and and so this kid this kid's grown
this kid's growing up with that
like this kid has to spend like what
rookie quarterback
in an arm memory certainly first overall
had to at during an actual football game
okay during the the live action of a
football game and regular season the nfl
how to go up to his coach and say
where's my running back how come he's
not on the field
you know i still cannot believe right
that is an unbelievable
situation right so how can he be
evaluated how are we doing right that's
what i'm saying how can he properly be
fully evaluated
as i get it that's a good that's a good
rebuttal i get it um
but there is the on-field product and
like
you know the owner and the quarterback
are so important and some i mean
trevor has a lot of talent so somebody
will be so i'm just saying
it has been a rough year at quarterback
for the jaguars and i'm going to be
really interested
in especially if you have someone who
has multiple opportunities
what they think of this job overall
ian rappaport here on the rich eisen
show now what's next for urban um
is it is it uh some legal fight uh
what's going on is there a settlement
what is it because you know you're there
there's a lot of reasons where you can
fire him and try and maybe not pay him
his full amount the question is is are
they timely enough to be able to do it
right here right now
as of december 15th when they fired him
or 16th depending on what time of night
it was what do you think i i don't first
of all i don't know the answer to that i
am going to try to find out but i do not
know okay hard for me to imagine
that they paid him the
all of it
like i guess anything's possible
but hard to imagine
um
because there's so many different times
you could fight him for cause
you know at least two
which is a lot two is more than most but
one happened in august and what happened
in october and this is the middle of
december right i mean i'm not a legal
expert oh yeah you're right one all
august yeah yeah the kicking of the
kicker and then the uh and then the uh
uh not going on the team plane and
getting caught on twitter uh at your
local establishment i can't believe i'm
saying these words man i i can't
honestly
it's just i i can't believe it that's
crazy but but you know what i'm saying
that's that's why i ask about because
you know which
well hold on a second though which of
these things is more ridiculous but i
would go through the list
signing tim tebow
at like 34 to be a title i know but i
was an allegedly racist
special teams coach when he was a pariah
benching
one of the best running backs in the nfl
because he fumbled not going on the team
plane so you could dance with a woman
who is not your wife and then be totally
fine as social media films all of it
which is an unbelievable
lack of awareness
kicking a kicker the only thing you need
a kicker for is his leg and why in the
world would you kick
anyone let alone a kicker at least punch
him in the arm
but ian too how about just the preseason
when he said there was an open
competition at quarterback costing
trevor lawrence first team reps when you
knew he's going to be the starter the
whole time
how about caring about preseason he told
his assistants he wanted to win games
because he was upset about losing in the
preseason
that is nuts i i honestly but that but
then again that's that was my point and
that has been my point this entire time
is i uh you know the question coming in
is how will he do is is how will he
handle the losing right and so he
handled the losing in professional
football the way that it appears he
would handle losing in college
except you know he didn't have to employ
that losing uh mental reaction
except once a year if not once in two
years sometimes
and this is a once a week thing and that
is not the way you go so i would think
he would no hey going into this i i
might lose more times this year than i i
would lose in at ohio state the entire
time so i'm gonna have this reaction i'm
gonna have that plan and all whatever he
just was just going with his id man
you know and and that that just didn't
work
at all which is obvious so long story
short though is what it what is next for
him do you think he's done coaching i
think he's gonna go to college at some
point after uh after a stint on
television somewhere but what do you
think what what's what's your general
sense or what you might already be
hearing or we're still all just stuck in
the the the what just happened of urban
right now what do you think
yeah i mean
i i
i hope nobody hires him um
and on tv i'm sure somebody will oh but
yeah
you know it'll probably take a year to i
think you know i imagine he will get a
college job i imagine he would get a
very good college job i don't know why
he would want one i don't know why he
wanted this one
um
i don't know um
i don't know it's all
he should not be back
he should go work on his family and just
do that stuff but i'm sure he will
resurface i'm sure he'll get a great
college job and i'm sure he'll win a
bunch of games
um i do not think he'll be back in the
nfl
so before i let you go uh now that
there's this rule that you can interview
candidates for uh head coach
from other teams with in the playing
season that's the first time we've seen
that
do you think do you think we'll see some
other interim head coaches in the near
term here in the nfl
ian yeah i really do um
and i guess it's good
you know because
if you're going to move on just do it
right like there's no reason to
i mean honestly like if you're having a
you know if you know you're firing your
coach we've seen him
plenty of times like last year
you know we knew adam gates was getting
fired for a long time and he coached the
whole season like i get it but
like why right so just move on cut ties
and then you can start the process and
what i do expect though is now you have
two teams that can start the process
other teams are going to feel like
they're behind and i would imagine they
react to that as well who are those
teams you want to help identify what
you're thinking what you're hearing well
i mean
you know we know some of the teams that
have coaches who need to win
to
to stay employed i think the bears would
certainly be
um would be one of those teams you know
the vikings your team who i think you'd
like you'd like zimmer to win maybe win
some games and keep winning i mean part
of the problem though rich is like
um
everyone's bunched up so like
theoretically like the vikings couldn't
make the playoffs
or they could go the other way
you know right um it's really it's a
weird year because everyone's so close
but i imagine this will play itself out
over the next little bit ian rappaport
thank you sir you'd be well we'll chat
on sunday obviously have a good one
brother look forward to richard
rap sheet i follow him you should too
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here